il y a quatre agences importantes qui
évalue la solvabilité du pays maudit
fournit une note triple à au canada
c'est la plus haute note depuis mai 2002
stijnen poreuse même chose triple a
depuis juillet 2002 dbrs accorde aussi
la meilleure note au canada depuis
décembre 2002 est fait chaque corde
élèves note triple a depuis ou 2004 une
cote de crédit plus faible ça signifie
des coûts d'emprunt qui pourrait être un
peu plus élevé sur les marchés
internationaux pour en parler clément
gignac économiste en chef de
l'industrielle alliance bonsoir clément
gignac
bonsoir pour vous qu'est-ce que ça
signale cet abaissement la note de
crédit
je pense que c'est un drapeau jaune ne
connaît vocaux niveau du gouvernement du
moins du côté la part de l'agencé fitch
puisque comme vous mentionnez il ya
quand même d'autres agences de crédit et
les autres sont quand même plus suivi
plus importantes on parle de moody's
mais pour venait décision de l'agencé
fitch
clairement on est inquiet surtout dans
un contexte de gouvernement minoritaire
et le fait que plusieurs provinces aussi
devront compter sur mike fédéral pour
retourner avec des budgets sur le à 15
heures le retour vers une autre chez toi
plus soutenable au niveau des finances
publiques
on y lit également d'autres raisons un
gerald il ya aussi le fait que le
gouvernement a une dette pour le
gouvernement mais le canada une dette
extérieure importante et dans une mesure
que le prix du pétrole ne retournera au
programme un peu au niveau qui était et
secteur pétrolier de la difficulté à ce
moment là on doit compter sur les fonds
étrangers pour financer notre dette
extérieure et ça aussi je pensais
préoccupe l'agent 6 mai ce que vous
dites là est ce que fut tu dis c'est
essentiellement vrai qu'une analyse très
intéressant pourquoi ça mène cette
agence là à dire on abaisse notre note
et les autres les autres agences
conserve le triple a pour ligne fera ça
c'est une bonne question mais comme
l'avait mal faits l'avait signalé dans
vos propos d'ouverture c'est que cette
agence le semble plus sévère
premièrement c'est le 2e prix 2,1 après
tout les autres abandonné la cote triple
hommes aussi ont ils l'ont fait en 2004
n'ont pas en 2002 deuxièmement ce qui
est surprenant c'est qu'il bouche avait
en main le portrait économique ou la
mise à jour qu'on doit avoir de 8
juillet alors que les autres agences
selon moi vingt ans et plus
même ses mots disent qu'ils disaient aux
modeuses mais qu'il y avait pas
l'intention de changer vraiment des
perspectives sur canet d'aude ont
clairement fils est plus sévère mais il
ya plus grand qu'un pas que ces marchés
pourquoi parce que fish s'est un peu
moins important aux yeux des
investisseurs puisque justement les
moins actives au niveau de l'association
des entreprises du canada donc est ce
que les bains savoie moi je pense à
voile à l'automne clairement parce que
on était encore on le voit bien aux
états unis.le c'est loin d'être finie la
corvée 19 et il y aura peut-être
d'autres interventions mais claire mais
se dit que on a on a en fait les pays à
l'oeil évidemment il n'ya pas juste
qu'elle doive faut penser que l'ensemble
des pays comme le mentionnait monsieur
prudhom doit faire les choses pour
soutenir travers l'entreprise
donc c'est là pour l'impact dans les
années 90 d'autant plus que le service
de la dette actuelle mais musquin de
beaucoup plus cher de l'été des années
90 donc faut voir les choses une base
relative est actuellement le
gouvernement fédéral peut emprunter pour
les dix prochaines années avec des tons
neutres et 15 points de base inférieur à
celui des etats unis
alors que dans les années 90 dont
doivent payer 100 points de base de plus
que les états unis dont la situation
n'est vraiment pas comparable mais c'est
quand même un signal de faire attention
donc autrement dit ça va pas faire
monter les coûts d'emprunt vraiment du
canada à ce stade s'il faudrait vraiment
ça soit suivie par les autres agences
comme moody's et s&p
d'ailleurs on a vu qu'il n'y a pas une
grande réaction le haut niveau des
marchés financiers depuis 48 heures est
ce que c'est quand même signale un
avertissement un petit message au canada
comme quoi il faudrait peut-être est un
petit peu plus clair un peu plus complet
dans l'énoncé budgétaire un peu plus de
transparence avec une vraie mise à jour
que je dirais même budget qu'on a
toujours pas vu en 2021 a trait au
minimum moi de voir une mise à jour un
peu similaire que québec vient de faire
sans faire des projections les cinq
prochaines années on pourrait au moins
savoir pour l'année en cours vers où
concerts voici maintenant on doit s'y au
directeur parlementaire du budget pour
ce faire mais que la ministre se
prononce
mais évidemment il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes faut combiner cela avec
le fait que
cette agence est plus inquiète aussi
kanter ou rebond un peu comme le fonds
monétaire international
cette année on parle d'un recul
d'économies mais canadienne de lob de 7
à 8%
mais l'an prochain on parle d'une
reprise peut-être juste de l'ordre de 4%
la porte cette agence donc forêt ça sera
un peu aidé soit de compter sur un
rebond très rapide au niveau de
l'activité économique pour venir à bout
du déficit budgétaire est ce que le
canada a trop dépensé trop empruntés si
je me trompe pas les empreintes s'élève
à 12% de son pib par rapport aux autres
pays
en fait ça dépend si on regarde avec
d'autres pays c'est comparable sont de
ce qui se passe du côté de l'allemagne
sont quatre heures par du côté des états
unis
mais vous savez le taux de taxation est
différent aux états unis et toute
taxation beaucoup plus faible au canada
donc on a une marche fiscale au besoin
le conte pour aller chercher ce qui est
pas le code du canada ou qu'on est quand
même plus taxés que les états unis donc
faudra quand même faire attention mais
clairement je pense qu'au niveau des
agences de notation on va surveiller ça
de près en même temps comme j'ai dit
plus
précédemment on est bien loin des
situations de velours 20 ou 30 ans quand
que le service de la dette représentait
17 dollars par 17 sous excusez-moi par
dollar de revenu actuel alors
questionnant on parle seulement de 7
sous par dollar de revenu donc situation
moins inquiétant mais quand même fou re
voir ce qui se passe au niveau de la
situation économique et le développement
au niveau de la coque
il ya la colombie-britannique qui garde
son triple à c'est assez cocasse parce
que moi de mon expérience j'ai jamais eu
qu'une province est une cote de crédit
plus élevé que le pays souffrait donc
faudra voir si ça sera suivi de la part
de l' agence fitch par une décote de la
colombie-britannique mais moyen terme
c'est assez rare qu'on voit ça mais
c'est dans cette école de série mais il
faut avoir encore une fois comme si les
autres agences de notation s'ils vont
emboîter le pas à la chance fitch merci
beaucoup clément gignac pour cette
analyse ce soir on plaisait